[Applaudissements]
mais petite beauté on va se retrouver
dans un instant dans touche pas à mon
poste bien sûr pour une émission normal
puisqu'on aura le conseil de classe
d'isabelle morini-bosc dans un instant
on aura bien sûr le top 5 on aura nos
invités on aura un nouvel humoriste
voilà qu'on vous faire découvrir qui
s'appelle maxime castle qui sera avec
nous autour de la table très vite qui
est exceptionnel on parlera avec yvan
attal de son film on parlera aussi nous
aussi karim benzema parce qu'ils veulent
en parler de karim benzema parce que
c'est aussi de la télé parce que ça
passe partout aujourd'hui il ya des
inondations dans toute la france vont
d'ailleurs on embrasse tous ceux voilà
qui qui sont dans la panade dans les
inondations etc
et c'est vrai que tout le monde ne parle
que de karim benzema
on parlera de ce traitement médiatique
mais avant tout on voulait parler d'un
collègue à nous qui nous a quittés un
mec qu'on adorait emmanuel maubert
malheureusement nous a quittés hier soir
on a pris ça juste à la fin de touche
pas à mon poste
emmanuel faisait partie de l'équipe de
touche pas à mon poste
l'an dernier ils étaient avec nous on a
passé des moments exceptionnels avec lui
il était aussi a également avec moi
voilà je le voyais très souvent sur
europe 1 il était même question je vous
le dis qu'ils reviennent un peu l'année
prochaine et manuel m'avait dit voilà ça
me ferait marrer de revenir avec vous
autour de la table de touche pas à mon
poste
et c'est vrai qu'il ya on était très
très ému de la perte de notre camarade
tout le monde l'a connu ici hein je
crois que tout ce qui est qu'ils sont là
thierry moreau en plus des pieds sur
europe1 donc forcément vous avez très
bien connus emmanuelle alors emmanuel
déjà ce qu'on peut dire c'est qu'il a
été chroniqueur autour de la table et je
me rappelle de sa première l'a promis sa
première route il est auto la table il
était très stressé emmanuel d'être avec
nous il m'avait envoyé un texto il m'a
dit je ne sais pas si je vais arriver à
trouver de la place et après il avait
dit j'étais porté par l'énergie c'est
génial et est vraiment et c'est un grand
grand professionnel des médias regarder
la première d'emmanuel maubert dans
touche pas à mon poste au regard des
manuels
[Applaudissements]
j'ai des amis parce que c'est des habous
et vous étiez chez des amis beaucoup
voient là et vous êtes venus chez nous
vous en faites vous avez sauté d'une
chaîne à l'autre ça comptera mais voilà
et emmanuel est ce que ils vous ont bien
accueilli ah oui non très très bel
accueil vraiment vous êtes très très
gentil cialiste médias donc on pourra se
tourner vers 21 12 yona enfin dans les
visions et emmanuel maubert et c'est
vrai qu'il était chez nos amis ii de
settat vous voilà qu'on embrasse
également qu'ils sont très tristes
aujourd'hui et qui sont vraiment nos
amis aussi alors thierry vous vous
l'avez côtoyé sur europe 1 vous l'avez
côtoyé ici dans touche pas à mon poste
ma chose sourires qu'ils étaient frères
chaleureux sincère son humilité mois il
m'avait enlevé un petit mot en disant tu
sais s'il vient tous par mon passé pas
pour plan de ta place etc
on est complémentaires et c'est donc
vraiment beaucoup d'humilité et puis
c'était un mec de chiffres il avait
toujours des infos des infos des infos
et des chiffres et d'ailleurs il ya un
extrait ci voulait qu'on le regarde
regarde emmanuel on pense bien à lui 7 %
de parts de marché 410 mille
téléspectateurs
emmanuel maubert vous confirmer les
chiffres vous êtes le monsieur chiffres
du jour et ben absolument savent combien
les haies 1 c'est la meilleure audience
et de même le démarrage la semaine
dernière lundi pour la première émission
60 minutes et après ça et ça c'est à
saab et souilhe effectivement en irak et
6% de part d'audience
ça marchera je suis pas d'accord sur les
missions en faire mais moi j'aime bien
ça on va voir un petit extrait et j'en
ai envie on va en parler dans un instant
et manière le pâté en tout cas j'aime
bien quand vous donner les chiffres vous
êtes vous est claire non mais c'est vrai
que c'est thierry moreau qui m'a refilé
c méfiez vous quand même il peut vous
envoyer dans le mur
c'est vrai il faisait même confiance à
thierry mauron pense très fort bien sûr
à à la famille des manuels et à tous ses
proches et celle où emmanuel ils ces
petits déguisés je me rappelle pas dans
ces tabous un jour en superman salua les
extrêmement bien et gilles ils s'étaient
déguisés également chez nous - oui c'est
ça qu'est ce que je retiens moi c'est
non seulement sa gentillesse mais aussi
son humour et sa dérision il jouait le
jeu à chaque fois notamment comme cette
fois-là cette occasion où il était
déguisée en mariée au bras de jean luc
lemoine
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'ai de loi mais dans le plus grand
silence
trente ans de journalisme au plus haut
niveau et ce à une famille respectable
négritude des amis tout ceci qui
disparaît souvent le rêve devient
réalité
vraiment excellent et emmanuel vraiment
excellent alors et isabelle beau si vous
voulez bien connue parce que oui vous
étiez journaliste vous êtes journalistes
ou des médias à rtl et c'est vrai que
vous échangez beaucoup avec emmanuel
mais on est et on s'appelait les frères
et les soeurs amis je l'avais fait venir
avec moi au grand journal de canal + la
première année et l'année d'après à rtl
après il nous a rejoint europe hamon
était resté super proches et j'étais
d'autant plus ravi de le voir ici et en
plus j'étais mise en cause dans un petit
sketch un jour il a pour jouer le jeu et
jouer le jeu à fond et il était il était
sur le plateau il y avait un jeu avec de
la nourriture
et là vous ne l'avez fait un petit gag
et je suis un petit peu en cause dedans
c'est parti attention c'est parti
allez-y allez-y toujours qu'est ce qui
s'est passé là-bas à laisser caresser
non c'est de la masse non c'est quoi ça
c'est un char c'est un à temps et non
c'était isabelle morini bosc
[Applaudissements]
merci emmanuel maubert
vous avez vu emmanuel kiprop d'uruk à
manger quand même que c'est ce qui se
fait plaisir et c'est vrai que la même
texture
c'est pour ça qu'on a pensé à vous voilà
alors enora vous vous connaissiez aussi
bien emmanuel en plus vous voir vous
entendiez bien tous les deux ont été
souvent un côté et mon voisin de classe
et où l on est tous très émus ce non
seulement il était gentil cultiver ses
rangs une des personnes les plus
gentilles condé rentable vraiment si
vraiment ça ne vous dira du mal des
morts mais je vous jure c'est vrai
personne ne vous dira du mal d'emmanuel
maubert ce que vous avez raison il
attend quelqu'un disparaît on a sa voix
la tendance à dire oui c'est quelqu'un
de fabuleux c'était quelqu'un de
merveilleux il était voilà il était
génial n'a aucun défaut mais je vous
jure vraiment là en l'occurrence pour
emmanuel maubert
c'est vraiment le cas c'est vraiment je
connais pas les personnes qui a dix qui
m'a déjà dit du mal d'équipés déjà dit
du mal d'emmanuel maubert
je n'aime pas emmanuel vraiment c'est
celle unanime il avait vraiment il avait
beaucoup à dire grossir alors tellement
d'humour que même parfois ils s'auto van
est et ses sacs étaient bien aussi avec
manu c'est l'auto dérision va regarder
un petit extra urbain et passez vous
êtes lyon regarde d'encore me suis mis
en garde un peu comme ça et alors voilà
je vais un peu réglé son compte
non mais j'ai du coup lequel que tu
rajoutes été battu ce mois ci leur
cheminement de cette fête la mouche pas
la guerre
mais chut
[Applaudissements]
enfin vous vouliez dire tous un petit
mot sur emmanuel et jean michel aussi
bien sûr vous connaissiez avant touche
pas à mon poste
il faisait partie des rares personnes on
l'a tout de suite envie de faire partie
de sa bande de potes ont relaté un
jouissif qui aimait les bons vins la
bonne bouffe les apéros entre potes etc
donc on avait on avait envie de faire
partie de son cercle voilà ils étaient
très accueillants très sympa très drôle
très cultivé c'est vraiment une énorme
perte et vous vouliez nous montre un
extrait un extrait voilà allez on a
beaucoup parlé de l'autodérision un jour
je l'avait désigné pour se déguiser en
cafard voilà il a fait il a vraiment
avec bonne humeur et la jouer je vais
pas non mais il ne rechignait jamais un
mois regarde reste on some restons
dignes est ce que vous pouvez me donner
les 110 comme ça oui et union jeux
rigolos dirait qu'il va jouer dans au
nom de la rose alors mais c'est encore
serré les chiffres non mais ça va très
très bien fonctionné 7,7 cette année
encore voilà et emmanuel maubert voilà
on pense très fort donc à sa famille à
tous ses proches
emmanuel tu vas nous manquer très fort
et je pense qu'on peut tous le dire ici
toute l'équipe de touche pas à mon poste
on t'aime fort voilà allez tout de suite
générique on se retrouve avec toute
l'équipe pour contrer de classe
d'isabelle on est libre c'est parti